um
i think this is working let's double
check
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be doing
a live broadcast this is kind of just
spur of the moment an idea i had
um
so the topic of the broadcast today is
what makes a man and a woman wife
material and when would you say that
their standards are too
high
um i hear a lot of stuff in the
manosphere about how women have too high
of standards
um so yeah i just wanted to talk about
it
let's so i put the link in the chat
let me make sure this is working because
sometimes i go live and i realize i'm
not actually live
[Music]
oh yay it's working okay
so i put the link in the chat can i pin
it
it's been a while i know i know i'm back
you guys are gonna get more consistent
content i'm actually
really excited for a couple of videos i
have coming out
um okay so let's keep going with the
topic
for me i think that one of the biggest
mistakes that i see women make is they
misconstrue like flashy things for
character
because anyone can fake a flashy
lifestyle that's very easy to do
you can rent a car
half the time people make a lot of money
they're spending more than they have
and
you see women get so wrapped up in
you know just like the flashiness the
gifts the presents that they're not even
really evaluating the guy's character
and it's interesting because in the
manusphere it really seems like they
equate money to character and i
disagree
um
but
let me know if you guys disagree in the
chat um what's up rome
you're a funeral director
wow
okay
and the other interesting thing is you
don't always know who the most
successful men are and i think that
is something that girls get wrong a lot
um
like my dad is probably the most
successful guy that i've ever met in my
life right i say that a lot i love my
dad if you guys can't tell um literally
he's so cool and
that man
it's funny i talked to him today and
we're going skiing to colorado
and he
i said i'd like to go but i was like i
can't afford the ticket if you guys want
me to go
like i need you guys to pay for the
ticket if not
you know i oh gosh is my makeup smeared
if not i totally understand right
and
so he says oh it's okay i'll drive you
i'm like
this man
is a
multi multi-millionaire right like
he's he doesn't want to pay for the
plane ticket so he's going to drive me
first what is it
a 15-hour drive i'm like dad do you not
value your time he doesn't
not a bad state from a visual
perspective yeah i love colorado i'm
going on
uh i don't know like the 17th or 18th i
think
but yeah guys call in i have the chat
link
and the topic today i already said it
before but i'll say it again
um the topic tonight is what makes
someone husband material and what makes
someone wife material because it seems
like the ideal and the manosphere
is
like a housewife and it's so interesting
because i asked my brother i said would
you rather date a lawyer
or um
a waitress and it's funny too because my
whole life my brother
has always said he doesn't respect a
girl that isn't
in like a good job like he always said
he wouldn't date teachers because he
just didn't respect their like work
ethic
um and i know that's probably not the
norm like i've listened to enough enough
men's content to know that's an
exception that's not the rule but i just
grew up in a family where we really
value work ethic
and that's that's like what you are
judged on as a child that is what your
whole life
the favorites in the family are always
the ones that work the hardest um
so
and
you know it's not
i guess it's not to say that the
waitress doesn't work hard um
but
you know if if you're 30 and you're
still doing that i guess there's like a
lack of like drive or ambition to keep
moving up if you're not moving up in
management or in something like that
so
yeah i don't know i guess that's just my
family but i want to know if anyone else
in the chat has had that same experience
or if that's just my family
um
because i remember growing up when my
mom would tell my brothers what to look
for in a girl
and they would say is she smart and
they'd ask her major
and
then
it would like
whatever major it was
like they would they would heavily judge
them on like the harder majors
um it doesn't respect a teacher's work
ethic um okay so here's the thing
teachers do work hard and there are some
teachers that work very hard um
but also some don't
like
and the in
you can get by school and stuff with and
even having
like you can even have like a 20-year
career i've seen teachers that have
20-year careers and literally don't do
anything like they're so lazy
and
i'm not saying that's not possible if
you're an engineer
but
it's harder to do right it's hard to be
a lazy engineer it's hard to be a lazy
you know executive like the higher up
you go in the competence hierarchy it's
harder to do
the biggest lie is that working hard
equals financial success well you have
to work smart too
you can't you can't just work hard
like
i forgot what did they say the the guy
who pushes a heavy rock all day
um
versus the one who gets the the pulley
or whatever there's there's a saying
about it
um
but here's the thing you have to think
about it it's a numbers game on some
level on some level it is a numbers game
about the number of hours you put into a
profession
um my dad i don't know if he's
necessarily he's smart he's absolutely
smart but he worked 80 hours a week my
entire life
now if most people are working 40 to 50
hours
the guy working 80 is clearly working
harder
than 40 to 50. and how do you catch up
to someone that's working 20 to 30 extra
hours a week than you
like
good luck
like and some people are going to argue
oh that's not working like
harder
but so it's interesting though because
that's just
my experience is my brothers really
valued work ethic and they like my
brother would tell me that he would dump
girls oh we have someone
hi
hey parole we talked against we talked
the other night i don't know if you
remember
yeah
i can actually hear you this time this
is great
um
so
this is this is a great question
um i would say what makes a woman a wife
material for me is someone that values
the relationship that they have with
their man and their family above
pretty much everything else especially
things like the sisterhood
because even in dating and relationships
it's hard to find women
that will
put anything with the man even their
relationship over like the sisterhood
and like women and other women what do
you mean by the sisterhood so
the sisterhood is
that like the girls going out to the
clubs and stuff no no no i'm talking
even even when it comes to basic
fundamentals like
you know
uh
they defend women at all costs even at
the point oh okay
okay
i'm gonna put this years so like
anything that you
speak about as being a man or your
position as a man like women have it
worse you have to understand where women
are coming from women women women women
and it's just like
um
that's what one of the difficulties with
a lot of the guys that i know especially
dealing with older women
when they date is women defend
defend all women at all costs even
ratchet behavior you know you you can't
it
if you're a man and you call out bad
behavior or anything like that even if
it comes to like women they have to
defend it and everything even in
relationship even with their men we have
to understand where these women are
coming from like i can't criticize so
example you know if if i'm with a woman
and i try to criticize like a co-worker
at my work or something like that she's
like well you have to is it can't you
just listen to what i'm
i don't that's kind of
a bad
bad
example but
just a woman that values what they have
in their man with their man over
anything else and also
um
the black community
what makes a woman
like materials you have to have the
mindset where
stop trying to save the community before
you have your own stuff because a lot of
black women they want to save everyone
but themselves
they spend 20 30 years in a career
trying to save the community trying to
save you know save women and you know
do community outreach and get people
involved and stuff and then they wake up
from 45 years old with no kids
uh
and not married
and it's like you have to save yourself
build your own house first you know
raise your own kids first and then
like build with them get with a man make
a family get married then do outreach
and save the community with what's left
over
well a lot of black women they value the
community be you know or
or the profession or whatever over
anything else
do you think um i've noticed that the
people that i find that are most
engulfed in everyone else's problems um
just don't want to look at their own
because then you know that would require
self-reflection
and taking accountability if you noticed
that or would you say something 100
100 yes
like um i never oh even in the chat she
has she never worked and took half she
deserves that she raised two kids by
popping disney dvds and drinking wine
our sex work is hard work don't
criticize it
i don't even under
no no it's not um
no that's interesting what do you think
makes a man husband material on the
other end uh what makes me
husband material
for me is um
starting and staying in a masculine
frame
um
uh
being able to i i think what makes a man
a husband material now is um
i think it's good for a couple
particularly before you get married to
state what your goals are
and
as a man you stick to them no matter
what because in my experience i spent
over 16 of my 40 years on this planet in
relationships are married and
in every relationship i've been in the
woman's been the one to want to change
the goals of the relationship marriage
around and as a man you have to be able
to successfully
um
navigate that like emotional turmoil and
men we've lost the art of of being able
to confront
the women that we care about like you
get to be able to confront
when when the woman wants to deviate
from the past
or she starts being turmoil to the
relationship
you need to be able to like confront the
woman even if it hurts you because women
don't understand like it hurts us men to
confront the women
that we care about or um you know or or
to make or to hurt their feelings or do
any of that but there are times as a
minute where you have you have to be the
one to stay the course
like you have to be the person you know
if you you know especially when it comes
to things like finances or anything like
that like you have to be able to stay
the course
what's an example of a time
a woman like made you go to a different
path or course or changed your goal
what's their what's an example of either
one that happened to you or a common one
you see
uh so
i think
last time
we talked
i told you i was uh i was married and
divorced
and my ex
she was a
uh
a student
uh at a college that was just like a
party school
and we were long distance like the last
year of our relationship and um
i found out that she was cheating and
spending spending a bunch of money and
it's funny because um
uh i look back on it now and it was a
simplest stupid thing to to do but i was
willing to actually work that out at the
time really she's like let's go to
therapy
and uh i said okay
but what made me leave her was um
at the beginning i remember two days
before we got married you know i told
her
my career path and i said you know i'm
going to have to end up moving around to
be able to be
successful are you okay with that she
said yes and then she said you know
that she wanted to be a physician
assistant and she had just got done with
community college so she said for the
next like four and a half years five
years i'm going to be a student are you
but i'm going to get my pa degree my
master's physician position studies and
then you become become a pa and i said
okay well if that's a plan
we're not
like
that's what we're going to focus on
and so what made me
leave was i logged into her student
account and i saw that not only was she
the cheating part in the in the spending
the money but our life was on hold so
she can get to where
she said she wanted to be educationally
and professionally and i logged into her
student account and saw that she was
failing in
school oh
so she wasn't even taking it seriously
yeah and all of our life decisions were
on hold because
a lot of times when people
so that she wouldn't have children and
i'm like we are not having children
until you get that done because
the the likelihood of someone having
children in college and getting done
it decreases by like a significant
percentage i don't know the percentage
off the top of my head and i was like
you know if we have kids before
if we had children before you get what
you your educational goals professional
goals done
uh and you don't get those done
you're gonna resent me in these in these
children you know for the rest of your
life i've seen it happen you know these
you you robbed me of my dream type you
know yeah so that's what happened with
me i was like yo
uh
and i look back on it now and the fact
that i was willing to
you know to go to counseling over
you know
financial misuse and cheating and stuff
i laugh at myself now but
um
that wasn't the kicker the kicker was we
originally agreed that she was going to
do that i was going to do
certain things she was going to do a
certain thing and she was completely off
the course
so that's what made me leave i said we
agree that you are going to get
these two degrees and be at a certain
place and place at a certain time i'm
taking every i'm i'm using all of my
resources i
already have my two degrees i'm using my
resources to help you get there i'm
giving you every single avenue
everything you say you need to be able
to achieve these goals i'm doing it and
you just don't give a [ __ ]
right
so
um
when so that's why you you say like stay
the course because you were willing to
like leave in that situation yeah and a
lot of guys wouldn't have been yeah
there comes a time
a relationship where one person has to
see where the ship is floating the the
more logical you know i think most of
the time time is the man but sometimes
it's the woman too
you see where the ship is floating and
you have to choose to either stay on it
or get off
and you know fortunately for all of my
relationships you know i i i've seen
where the ship was floating after a
couple years and you know i just you
know i get off the ship and it's funny
because
fate has it where every single one woman
i've broken up with has come back around
to me somehow and i see where their
lives are and they're exactly where i
thought they'd be
yeah um i think one lesson everyone has
to learn at some point in their life is
that you can't change people
and like people show you who they are
early on and you can either believe them
and like take it or leave it
i don't know if that's was the same in
your case but uh you know yeah i would
say that a hundred percent
um you
and
it's funny
um i had to evolve past being like a
fixer-upper guy like
finding a woman and oh i'm gonna put my
time and effort into her she's gonna
sprout into like a butterfly that guy
that never happens
ever
i mean how many guys do you know that
are super lazy and then all of a sudden
become like super hard workers
i'm sure it happens but for me like
that's rare i would say maybe 30 years
ago it happened a lot but
so one of the best parts about feminism
is it's freed women from having to be
in the kitchen
and just being housewives and stuff
but
it's also freed men from like
i mean we don't have
some of my female friends
who are dating anything that starts with
men have to or men better is invalid now
we don't have to do anything
if we don't want to
wait you live in um dc right that's who
you said last time oh my gosh it's bad
there
oh my gosh i have a friend that went out
there and she was like
pretty
not like a feminist at all and then
after two years there she was like crazy
indoctrinated into all that yeah
so yeah
this isn't quite atlanta where it's like
17 women per each for one man but i
think it's like five women or six women
with priest man
and
everyone just cares about their work and
their positions and their job and stuff
and it's funny because dating out here
i think i think i told you last time the
hardest part about being a single man
out here and like a professional is
you meet these women and
especially after 30 like right around 32
33 and they're just tired they're just
tired they're like man i've been out
here at this job for 10 years
and but
they're everyone's
most people's identities in dc
is like tied to their job
but the biggest difference between men
and women is women they just get tired
i'm just tired of this but they can't
shut it off
and so
um you meet these women who have the
same mindset
as your friend and it's like imagine
your friend dating
oh she's married now actually oh really
yeah she changed
her mind around he just he just or did
she find a beta male sin
i don't think he's a sip he's just more
like the manosphere would probably call
him a simple i just say he's laid back
like he doesn't care what she like her
political stuff is not did he just
um i don't i think that means yeah he's
no no no he's she's a lawyer he's an
engineer so i think they both do well i
don't know who makes more than him in dc
she probably makes more money in him um
i don't know i i just know he's an
engineer she's a lawyer but
but just just just tell me real quick
your friend
you know
how she is and she was indoctrinated
with this stuff
how would you as a okay
take away that her husband is a
laid-back type of guy like imagine
you're a competitive ambitious guy
how would you date a woman like your
friend how do you think it would go oh
gosh i actually i come into this
situation often as a girl because
a lot of my like world views align a lot
more with guys like i just find myself
agreeing more like guys just make more
sense like logically
and um
on a lot of things
like like with feminism with all that
stuff and so it's interesting because
i'll come into situations where girls
will say things that i really disagree
with but i'm friends with them and i
don't want to like
ruin that friendship you know
so i i don't know the girls are hard to
criticize
it like i'm not even gonna lie to you i
have a hard time doing it as a female
with girls
and maintaining a relationship so i have
no idea how you would do that in a
relationship
you said that
last
show that i listened to that you tried
to red pill
uh or no that you
you've had discussions with girls on
your
are the discussions different with the
women that you've
encountered in england than they were
back in the
united states or is it generally the
same
um well the girls on my uk volleyball
team are actually mostly americans so
um they just really recruit americans to
play in the uk
so i would say they're pretty similar um
i would say because this is the first
like public school i've gone to i would
say there's more
more of it in like just because the
public school i think
but
yeah i don't
they're cool no not i would say it's a
little bit more like feministy just
because a lot of the girls are from
california
oh lord okay yeah yeah because
volleyball's big in california
um
yeah but i come into these situations
like i if you watched my last vlog that
i had i
was talking about
me and this one girl on my team were
talking about how we like looked better
when we were 20 pounds lighter yeah yeah
yeah yeah and it was just like i don't
even understand why this is an argument
i'm like if we were 100 pounds heavier
we would not be as attractive like
that's just a fact and then she's like
oh no like i don't agree with this
like this is just basic it's not
offensive like i was in high school it's
okay like
sometimes sometimes you take l's in life
you know you just yeah my main thing
about that video is um because you know
you
you did the lord's work making it
through that whole tick tock thing oh my
goodness like so my biggest problem is
and what women don't
what those
what large women don't understand is
confidence means that you accept it but
my problem is you trying to get
men to accept it as an attractiveness
standard
yeah like they they want men to be
attracted to them your your confidence
and men accepting it like you can be
confident all you want but but your
measure of your confidence working
is whether men find you attractive or
not and we do not there's actually a
girl on tick tock who is large
saying that
skinny girls skinny attractive girls you
should judge a man on how he treats your
fat friend
if he doesn't acknowledge your fat
friend and treat her with respect he's
not the type of guy that you should talk
to and it's like are you what
this is a a large girl on tick tocks
the only measure of success for or the
only measure of their confidence
is
is
is men being attracted to them
and so so they can say that their body
positive and confidence all they want
but it's just like
you're trying to get you're trying to
push this on men and we're just
blatantly saying no like mm-hmm
and i think and honestly i think that
like being a little bit unconfident in
your body
makes you make better decisions
i don't think that yeah like i don't
think like i've actually been doing
really well with like eating better and
like exercising but i don't think i
would do that if i wasn't a little bit
unconfident like that's i think you have
to hate yourself a little bit to lose
weight to be honest like at least at
least
a little bit
yeah
you got to um
and also
don't see weight loss as like
a map to a treasure
like it's it's a continual quest well
it's like it's habits when i was younger
i used to be i mean
i've gotten healthier with my language
at least you know but i try to you know
i
i've kind of caved and you know i don't
call someone fat you know and i don't
you i call it living a healthier
lifestyle and you can only be as healthy
as your lifestyle allows you know you
know you're in school you're doing
you're doing all these different like a
woman that has two kids and family and
stuff she's not gonna be able to be a
size four you know what i'm saying but
she can she doesn't have to be as size
18 either you know what i'm saying
[Music]
no
i just don't
so
have you
you probably went through a time where
you were having
negative conversations with your with
yourself about your body about body and
your brain
um
i think i think anyone that that that
goes on
that
like you're talking about the the whole
kind of hating hating your body to lose
weight i think one of the reasons how
you develop that is you went through a
time where you were uncomfortable with
your body
it but
how
how did you as a woman not fall into
this whole body positive
making you okay with those conversations
and making you not liking your body
my
mom
yeah i know my mom
my parents do not do the whole
like fat except like my mom has
been on a diet since i was very young
because she was super overweight till i
was
i don't know
like
maybe eight or nine and then she lost
like 50 60 pounds
and then so
she i don't know she's just taught me
like diet stuff ever since i was a kid
and that stuff really does not come
naturally to me at all like i i love
sugar i love junk food but
i don't know my mom has just ingrained
me from a young age and she does not
like obese people like
like i don't want to say she doesn't
like them as people but like the way
they look and like she's always told me
you'll have more opportunities like the
better you look
and it's like not nice and it's not it's
an uncomfortable truth but it's just
true you know
yeah
my dad
was like pretty privileged is like the
biggest privilege you can have
yeah you know
and it's funny because with the level of
of people being overwhelmed you know i
wouldn't say
thin
then privilege no never mind i was gonna
say something about the thing
i was like
i'd say that's like the benefits of
being yeah
yeah
are
more apparent now more than ever
uh mac did you have anything to add
about um
i don't know if you're talking or not
yeah i'm i'm here i just didn't want to
hop in don't know
i mean is my camera working i don't know
it's not um so what do you think makes
it um a girl wife material and a guy
husband material uh
[ __ ] it's uh it's kind of an interesting
question you guys i don't know if you
guys remember me i haven't really been
in a long-term relationship yet so i
can't really i can't really say too
specifically what makes uh i guess a
woman
like life material i mean
i as one thing i could say in particular
um it's maybe a bit more rare
unfortunately today got to be
cooperative and i guess the second thing
uh is gotta be able to stand to reign um
so
a lot of a lot of women online i was
looking at um
youtube videos from quite a lot of
craters um i guess and it's kind of
um i guess you could say not really like
the man of spear but like people just
talk about like uh
intergender relationships like the one
common theme is like okay you know like
financial security as kind of like the
reason for um as some people refer to it
as hypergamy
which is its whole thing i don't really
really want to get too much into it but
i i think even in that self doesn't
really touch into it because it's like
well you know you can be financially
secure making what like the median
income in america which is uh 40k uh
dollars um
a year and you can be financially secure
with that like why does a man have to
make i don't know like 70k a year to be
financially secure that doesn't really
compute
um
wait what why does a man have to make
70k a year to be financially secure
because you can be financially secure
and just be [ __ ] broke so like
it's okay what are you what are you are
you talking about okay so are you
talking about the definition of broke is
not being financially secure yeah so i'm
just confused as to what like
like you're kind of talking in circles
like you're confused
um so
so if you're if you make a certain
amount of income are you talking about
like spending habits like people that
make a lot of money and spend it all
it's just like um yeah yeah it talks a
little bit about that it's like well
just being financially secure and like
just regular conversation what it means
is like yo you don't have creditors
chasing after you you know you're not
about to be evicted
you're not worrying about where you're
living no no
it's not about like it's not about you
never want to have financial struggles
ever because that's just [ __ ]
unrealistic um no it's not go back yes
it is dude okay so last last
and what do you mean the financial we
just had a massive recession
a year and a half ago
people lost their jobs in 2008 you had
ambassador bakers in 2008 on wall street
they jumped out of their office room to
kill themselves because they lost their
jobs in 2008
at the beginning of the millennium
you had the dot-com bubble where people
had okay okay okay
lost your job okay this is my recession
this is my platform we're not gonna this
is my this is my channel
um okay so you're saying that you can't
be financially secure
because there are recessions is that
like what you're saying not necessarily
i'm just saying that you know
i i kind of sense that the standard some
people are expecting it's just
unrealistic it doesn't matter unless
you're like
okay do you think do you think a girl
should look for any level of financial
security in a husband i mean yeah some
level is responsible but it's their
respect
what
level what level of financial security
do you think women should look for that
that's the bare minimum requirement of a
girl that's fit feminine friendly not
not girls with not girls with two
baby daddies or combative any of that
[ __ ]
well
i just i just think you know anyone in
general you know you want to look for a
guy who's just holding a [ __ ] down you
know not being chased by a million
creditors he's someone who's
okay i need a dollar amount
i mean
because you can like say these like
broad topics but that's so broad it's
you're not really saying anything you're
saying like he shouldn't have creditors
chasing him down like yeah
duh
i i guess i mean if i had to give an
amount for like marriage i mean 50 50k a
year i know that's not exactly a very
high bar
i mean if you're making bullet flat
you're probably not
not in a very good
industry so uh
but go for it okay so 50k a year you
would say that's financially stable and
husband material that's like the bearer
for a girl that's fit feminine friendly
um i'm not i'm not sure i don't think i
quite catch your meaning by that but uh
i just think like i'm just i'm
clarifying like that that's your like i
mean it's okay if you want to give or
take five grand based on where you live
or something
oh it's fine i was just thinking like
well if you're going to get married like
you can't can't be broke i mean like if
you're not broke then like damn that's
that's a wrap but uh
i was just thinking like you can be like
slightly he can be middle class and
still be financially secure is all i was
really trying to say so i don't know if
we're talking past each other so i'm
sorry um it's okay um
what do you think
what's what's your name it's doug mpa is
it doug
yeah
um what do you think 50k is a bare
minimum for husbands
so
you set the criteria fit feminine
friendly cooperative
yeah a woman who's fit feminine friendly
cooperative one shouldn't i think should
never date a woman shorter than her two
you mean a guy
yeah a guy a guy
who's shorter than her
two i think
i think the top
considering
how rare that is nowadays
certainly
i'm speaking okay
in the black community
that's
that's less than 20
of the women so i would say the top 5 15
of black men make about seventy five
eighty thousand dollars a year so i'd
say i'd say
uh a a woman who's done the work like
you said he's fit feminine cooperative
friendly shouldn't marry a guy unless
he's making seventy five thousand
dollars a year and it's
it's taller than her because in the
black community that's less than 20
women cutting out a [ __ ] ton of people
singing that's cutting out a [ __ ] ton of
people
i mean
say for example i mean
i mean like what what percent of people
make 75k or more is it like 20
uh
i can't
like i don't know
men it's 15
15
okay so you're basically saying the top
20 percent of women should date the top
20 percent of men
well because you because you're you
would you would say that like only
20-ish percent of women are feminine
friendly
like based on your experience if that
if that
and
especially
they have to do the work
with the current narrative nowadays and
everything going on a woman has to do
the work
to be that
you know and so yes i think that women
who fit all everything you just named
they should be able to have access and
marry a man in the top 20 to 15
um interesting comment so this is
actually what i was talking about
earlier when yahoo flopped millions of
people went from i make six figures to a
year to i'm a multi-millionaire to
foreclosure um
and that's the one interesting thing
i've noticed about like super wealthy
people that stay rich um and i think
that maybe it was what you were getting
at mac
um a lot of people that make a lot of
money
um
often like spend it
you know so they don't stay rich and
it's like one one for one
foreclosure or one like bubble or
whatever happens like they go from rich
to broke
yeah
um is that what
yeah that's that's what i was saying a
little bit and like not to i guess dogs
myself or my father but my my dad is a
contractor and in this industry he can
go from mid six figures to low seven
figures depending on the year but and
it's also just like general things now
if you're like if you make like well
into six or seven figures i'm sorry for
consistent years and you're in a and
you're
you're at that point i assume you own a
business and things are growing pretty
consistently you know it's not looking
like some sort of asset bubble like
where we had with the very early days of
the internet and back in the turn of
millennium where you had dot-com bubble
everybody was creating new tech things
and a lot of people just sunk because it
kind of popped and speaking of that i
mean he had in 2008 he had i mean the
heart housing market crash he had
what is what is like stopping you from
saving like 20 of your income so you
have six months rent like lined up
um i would have to say
lifestyle creep for a lot of people
yeah but that that's like a choice you
know what you know what i mean so it's
not necessarily like for everyone
for everyone everyone in the middle
class and above it's
it's choice
it is it is individual choice i don't
want to let people just like blame
external factors but i mean you got to
also look at things at a because i mean
uh economics is just a a social uh
phenomenon and you can't really have a
uh economy just like one or two people
so people are consistently making wrong
choices you kind of have to look at that
a little bit
um but i i i was just really trying to
say
um
uh
for most people they're gonna be like
lows and highs of like uh financial
status now i'm not saying look you got
to tolerate you know your guy just like
completely losing [ __ ] everything car
gets just from a car gets repoed you're
out on the streets like you're in a
warming shelter right now like okay i
can understand not tolerating that but
like you know most people are going to
be middle class or somewhere around
there
most people you know take for example to
pandem now i work in entertainment so
for me it was a little bit hurt a little
bit more
but you know take you know 2020 you know
[ __ ] a lot of people lost their job and
it's not you can [ __ ] do about that
take 2008 uh people lost their houses
and you know we tend to have a recession
around every decade now i'm not saying
it's gonna you know don't uh you know
[ __ ] it be nihilistic do whatever you
want just get out get a credit card go
crazy because you're gonna be homeless
anyway i'm not saying that i'm just
saying like you know
expecting like i think like a lot of
people are expecting like absolute like
financial security like you know i will
never struggle in life and it's like oh
yeah they're setting yourself up well
that's that's definitely true that's
that like that's that's definitely true
um especially with like business owners
because it's like high risk high reward
um
but i'm sorry i don't know i don't know
what like did you have a question about
it or like what the
like are you just saying that yeah are
you just saying that there are
recessions every 10 years i i just think
it's like kind of i don't know if this
is like i mean my perspective of course
is falling we're all human beings here i
just think like a lot of like uh and a
lot of women youtubers i don't know if
you ever talk about this in particular
because i watch like a lot of people and
i don't have a very good memory but like
a lot of people will put like such just
like strong focus on like you guys got
to be financially secure and i'm
thinking like well
it's making me think like one
two things just like you know i never
you know can't can't stand the rain like
hey you know
i got what happens like you know because
i'll be going into engineering pretty
soon what happens if i get like laid off
and it takes me like a week to get a new
job are you like out the door then or
like in the past have you just been
dating guys that are just like [ __ ] bums
so like
that's kind of like what i think
here's the thing
um
and here's it
here's why i recommend because pearl has
a i think that your
your parents raise you raise you in this
mindset but mac
when you're approaching women or when
you're approaching the
job market
i would recommend this attitude
life is gonna suck sometimes
what are you gonna do about it
because you're talking about okay
sometimes like the the uh
economy sucks sometimes
people have it hard okay it's hard for
most people
you know and i'm a black guy you know
life is going to be harder for for me
like
a lot of people but i had to move past
the fact that life is hard
and figuring out a plan
to
what's going to happen when it does get
hard i.e did you choose a major in
college that's always going to be into
in demand are you in a business where
there there are recession-proof cities
like the
washington dc and the dmv area is the
most recession-proof
place in the country
okay
also one of those places do you have a
recession-proof
degree do you have do you have a
recession-proof job
you should be playing for those type of
these now because it's like i think that
you recognize that life it sucks for
some people or life is going to suck or
like it may suck for you now but you
gotta move into the mindset of
life is gonna suck what am i gonna do
about it
okay so i i get that so we mentioned
like um recession proofs jobs i mean
it's
it's a it's a seductive thought and i
mean i'm choosing engineering so i'm not
i'm not going to be in an entertaining
energy industry for like the rest of my
life at least i'm not planning on it but
like like like i took for example 2008
like yeah a lot of people get a degree a
master's degree in finance
you know if some not some new credit um
uh some new
um asset bubble comes out
[ __ ] everyone up i mean if you're
working out some
um
hedge fund or some investment bank that
takes a little bit more risk than other
people then
you know you know their their assets
could fail and they could start looking
at you like hey buddy you know
can't keep you on so like yeah like i'm
not trying to say like be like a total
doomer like oh you know you're never
going to be secure but like you got to
be realistic about it like
i think a lot of people conversations
you wouldn't have with the woman whose
wife material you should have that
conversation look if life starts to suck
what are we going to do about it yeah
yeah that's enough that's what i mean
just like standing to reign like
what's that's all i'm saying
no that's actually um because my parents
bought um an entire neighborhood in 2007
and they put their life savings into it
and then it was worth nothing
like overnight we almost lost everything
but
i don't know my dad just has always had
that mentality like we'll figure it out
and he just like i don't know smartest
guy i've ever met
but i don't know it's kind of like a
mentality i guess that's i just see in
like certain guys where it doesn't
matter what happens like they're going
to think their way out of it or figure a
way out of it or
i'm just going to push through it you
know yeah i get that it's like and
that's why like i always talk about like
characters more important than money
um because that's like that's an example
of character is like the mindset of
you know no matter what happens like i'm
going to figure out a way to get out of
this or you know we'll downsize if we
have to move it to an apartment for a
couple months or like do what we have to
do
um
that can be in all walks of life
i grew up i grew up poor
up until my parents graduated college
and
my parents
they pushed through the difficulty so
well because they had three kids going
to school that we were poor
like dirt poor and i didn't even know
because we had such a good time growing
up i didn't know we were poor until we
like moved to the northwest and we
literally moved on up
to the east side to a deluxe apartment
in the sky and i was like what the hell
like a front yard and you know what i'm
saying so like like
my parents
were so like secure that that things
were going to work out once that they
graduated school and they're putting
they're putting in the work now i never
stopped in flint growing up you know
what i'm saying i never saw you know
like i never i didn't once again i
didn't realize how poor we were until we
moved then
well because it's big because they had
they had character right they were just
going to work through it
and that's that's what i mean is like
and i it's it's hard to describe but
like people that have the same mindset
know exactly what i'm talking about yeah
right like
and i'm
it's it's just hard for me to say it
because um
i'm not sure because it's been what must
have been around two weeks or so but um
i'm not sure if you guys remember me
because it's like a second call-in show
i mean
uh i guess like yeah it is character but
you gotta realize um not to talk down to
anyone that's that's still a finite
resource so take me for example also
uh my dad wasn't always making this type
of money i did grow up a lot of my life
was on you know food stamps um
not section eight but we almost did lose
our almost got foreclosed on so my dad
has to go into bankruptcy do a shake
move to keep the house with that but um
you know
what would be let's check uh what would
be a just
short of a year ago i had a stroke
so
i'm 22.
so coming back working through that to
get to school they're they're like the
times and amount of times that i just
want to [ __ ] quit and be like bro
[ __ ] the [ __ ] i'm out it's almost uh
like a daily thought
it's it's
and i you know like i totally get uh you
know preserve you know do what you got
to do but like
yes you gotta it's it's just like
i i have to realize like mine wasn't i
mean all strokes are severe but mine
wasn't really that bad like there could
have been a chance where one i just
[ __ ] died too i would have been even
more cognitively compromised so it just
would have been a wrap
and but like it's it's
it's a it's a
fair bit of like um sampling bias and
not
you know get like super personal or
weird anything i believe you studied um
economics as your bachelor's in science
i believe
so you're uh you're aware of the
phenomenon of uh sampling bias right
sampling but i forgot what that means it
was a couple years ago all right so um
there's this i i guess this works yes
this works so this is uh i guess you're
in england so
um in world war ii uh the world air
force was looking they were losing a lot
of planes
so when members of a population are more
likely to be selected in a sample than
others okay
yeah so um you know not to be
long-winded but i is this work because
you're currently there so uh world war
ii england was losing our united kingdom
was losing a lot of planes to uh german
air raids and air combat so they were
looking at all the planes or coming back
managed to get back to the hangars and
and and not to get super nerdy but when
you're trying to like reinforce a plane
you can't put armor everywhere you have
to select places so all the planes that
came back um they had
the fuse lodge where like the pilots are
they were completely shot up all the
tons of bullet holes there so all the uh
engineers at the time were thinking like
um okay so we need to
uh we don't need to reinforce those it
is something weird so basically what
this whole experience this whole uh
study was that like
all the planes that came back were just
people who managed to survive like uh
every all the pilots and what were two
that got shot in the huge lodge just
didn't come back so
all the places that came back uh only
had holes in the wings and they were
able to like kind of scoot back to the
hangers but all the the planes got shot
down because like their pilot got
directly shot by the german uh planes
they came back so all the engineers
think like okay we're going to only
reinforce the wings because those are
the only problem areas of the plane
where in reality
the the actual um pilot's compartment
was a problem because but you couldn't
see that from the
limited sample because all the planes
that got hit in that area just [ __ ]
blew up so it's
like that's what i said i knew everyone
are you explaining sampling by i'm sorry
yeah just don't okay yeah i'm sorry i
realized i got really long-winded but
it's like it's it's like
it's very it's much easier to see the
people who kind of make it and i'm not
discounting anybody because this shit's
[ __ ] hard like never want to never
want to discount every once in sets but
this is like a lot of people who just
regard for whatever fact ace don't
[ __ ] make it
so well i mean i think
yeah that's like a given like some
people it doesn't work out for
but it's like you can't you can't help
the outcome
like there's nothing we can do to make
everything in life fair
like it's just not like
i got i got dealt with the best hand on
the planet like i cannot think of a
person that got dealt a better hand than
me and like some people just don't but
like what what is like what do we do now
yeah
so here's the thing
a couple of these first off
one of those
the best pieces of advice i got was
from my father he said when you face
adversity there's two
two knee-jerk reactions despair and
anger
okay
now
the biggest difference between despair
and anger is despair is an emotion of
inaction and anger
is is an emotion of action now us with
black men we've been taught not to i
think black people like
people people are afraid of us getting
angry
like
i was taught to not get angry
by society and my father helped me kind
of channel my anger into action so like
when i was in school with the full
schedule i had to work two jobs in
school and stuff i started getting sad
my dad would tell me like you need to
get angry about this go
go attack these problems like get pissed
off and go attack them
because
because you're gonna be successful if
you attack
i i guess if you find yourself sad in
life
kind of don't give up
angry
and go fix it like like go attack these
problems because you can fix them get
mad get upset get pissed off because
because because
it sounds to me like like you you feel
like you you've been
you've been
dealt a bad hand and you just want to
accept
defeat and what i'm saying is i mean i'm
about to graduate
prove them wrong
i don't
give a [ __ ]
about other people
get mad
go attack this stuff go fix it
it's it's like i i mean i get everything
you're saying it's it's like
but
one problem with using anger and i've
dealt with this is a lie quickly and i'm
not not christian but i mean quickly
turns into raft and i mean you see it
all the time and kind of like the
so-called manosphere like as soon as
someone touches like a gram of like
coochie and just become complete [ __ ]
douchebags or whatever it doesn't matter
how other people handle anger
it matters how you handle it
i mean i know i'm personally fine so
like
i'm just saying i mean like like you
have two arms two legs two feet two
hands ten fingers
ten toes
like and
just
like if you think that society is trying
to defeat you get mad and prove them
wrong man
i i don't have
[ __ ] to prove anyone i'm doing this
because i just want to have a decent job
um all right i i get what you're saying
i i don't know but it's i guess it's
kind of a
probably didn't speak too well for
myself uh speech unfortunately is still
a little bit difficult but i'm working
on it
probably in the next year i'll finally
get in speech therapy because
all medical services are like super hard
to get access to right now it's really
weird
uh but
yeah uh
really what just motivates me like i
don't know i just just want to be like
some
and
i accept like this is probably gonna
hurt my so-called like stock like it
honestly if i can go home and like
most of my shit's alright like okay
i have like three three months of rent
saved up you know
i can afford to put gas in my car or and
i can afford the car note you know i'm
not worried about you know being evicted
i can wear decent looking clothes
so i'm not looking like homeless or
anything
i'm i'm good like i don't need all this
like luxurious life i don't need like
the so-called lifestyle even the richest
people i know don't live that lifestyle
like i know i know someone worth 50
million plus
he's driven the same card for car for 20
years and those who do are usually
freaking broke as
that's one thing [ __ ]
learned about las vegas a lot of people
flex yeah they're broke as [ __ ] and yeah
and that's that's the thing that's why i
always
and this is what i wish more girls would
understand the guys that you think are
rich or not rich yes the guys that you
think are rich or not i have never
looked at a flashy car as a good thing
like i i it's just ingrained in me
because of my dad he's like
i you know i look up to him so much like
i always look for those traits you know
and like a person
um and he's just always ingrained that
like flashy cars are a waste of money
and like like same with expensive
watches he's like why would i spend that
much money on it i mean i can understand
if you're a lawyer and you know you need
that stuff for yourself yeah yeah so
but you must have one thing that you
because most people have one thing so
like what is your thing
that you
usually splurge money on are you like a
shoe person are you like a
you're not a watch person a handbag
person
your youtube equipment
what's that youtube equipment
that's what i spend my money on
and food chipotle but
eight dollars now so and i'm in the uk
so i can't afford it oh yeah it's
maybe sushi i would say yeah sushi is so
good man that's that's interesting do
you find yourself converting between uh
united states dollars and pounds off
then you have to pay like a lot of
exchange fees for that um i lost a ton
of money when i came here because the us
decided to print 40 of its currency last
year so
thank you for that
um
you know that forty percent of the
currency was printed last year yeah are
you talking about history
financial uh the general u.s i'm talking
about when they gave everyone money and
so um when you think that's a good thing
it's not necessarily because they just
hyperinflated the currency so when i go
to england and they didn't do that i
lose money
but
so
because if you give everyone in the
states like
if you print 40 of the money like if the
money's been printed for 100 years and
in one year you print 40 percent of it
you know that's
that's crazy
yeah
um
it's a factor a lot of it's um supply
side it gets complicated but uh i
believe you're gonna say something yeah
i know um sorry go ahead doug yeah i'm
not gonna no point in lecturing you
about your own degree so
well you know
back to your like original question you
know um
i don't see
i'm just going to read it
before i think
i always said that america is a country
of entitlement like
like being an american and being raised
in america like
every
american teaches entitlement to its
citizens but how you can offset that is
by putting in the work
and if you put in the work you should
you know you you should have a certain
lifestyle
um you know you should
that goes with women and husbands and
men and wives i just think that one of
the things about our society is women
women are taught to be entitled without
putting in the work and that they should
feel entitled to a certain type of
husband or man without putting in the
work whereas men have always been held
accountable for for doing the work so oh
for sure but i think it's because
we see women get away with it like i
remember one of the like bitchiest girls
on my volleyball team always had guys
after her always yeah
but
so you see like
get away with getting married though
like sex maybe or like relationships and
or maybe we do
yes we do i i see hot girls get married
that
to i would say
like
i'm not saying they stay married like i
would imagine oh yes yeah you know
staying married is the second thing
but
like i mean what even what's her face um
brittany reiner
did she not get married to an nba player
no she's
she's but they didn't get married are
she
just
you sure i swore she divorced them no no
they were never married oh really okay i
stand corrected
i swore she said she like divorced him
like two days after she gave birth
did you react to kevin samuel's
interview with her
no i should have asked you really should
because i'd be interested to see your oh
and this and just
one thing
yeah i've been watching for a while
i'm the guy that i always puts
the space bar slam
you slam your space bar when you're
stopping
no
you makes me so no this makes me so mad
about youtube because or my mic it's too
good it picks up on everything and i
don't know how to fix it like that has
been my issue everything's better than
that space wash land
like the mouse the a button the ship
anything but that because the space bar
makes a specific type of sound and the
way it bounces off the microphone
oh my gosh i know
you should react to captain jamie was
interviewing benny winner because
everyone thought that he was going to
cook her up
and
the best
i don't want to spoil it but you know
she she
yeah you just asked her you know what he
asked every other woman you know like
what what is your life going to be like
in 30 years and she was surprised she's
like
he i think she was surprised that kevin
didn't cook her up either but he just
made her really look at the grim reality
reality
every situation you know so yeah react
to it
i think it would be
women women like don't think long term
um like and that's something i find
myself having a hard time like bonding
with girls on
because i just don't meet many girls
that think about their lives in like 20
or 30 years
you know
um
yeah and so i could see why like a lot
of girls when they hit a certain age
have like a harsh reality that kind of
like wakes them up
especially her
yeah it all becomes due eventually um
for most people anyway even only fans
and like all that stuff i do not
understand um
like how these like do you not think
about your grandkids or like and that's
now
your children years from now
because like
how long have you been on tick tock bro
um like uh two years maybe how many
two years maybe
total total on tick tock
maybe two years yeah okay so
all these because we're just now seeing
you know because youtube has really has
only been around for what 13 years or
something like that um so so we're just
now seeing these wannabe youtube stars
you know getting to their 30s
and trying to like okay it didn't work
out for them so now they're going to try
to get real jobs so it's going to be
interesting to see
when these instagram
and tick tock stars you know because
it's showbiz oh
yeah no it's actually interesting
because of um
i actually met like because of my
ex-boyfriend like i met a lot of like
the bigger like tick-tockers
um and like charlie demilia was offered
a hundred thousand dollars to follow
someone back
and she turned it down because she just
didn't want to like that's how much
money some of these tick talkers are
making like
200 000 300 000 for one post a lot of
them
once again yeah
if you're putting like regular content
out there but the people that are doing
this like crazy extreme stuff
or saying you know
just you could put yourself in a
position where
you know
when you're 35 or 40 or 45 what's your
life going to be like you know what i'm
saying
and so it's a it's going to be
interesting 10 years from now
how this whole thing pans out
it hits woman in a lot of ways
especially heart you know
i think you know i think on a balance on
a lot of things it tends to pretty much
balance out you know we got it good in
some ways they got it [ __ ] some other
ways
but you know
being a woman and the entertainment
industry is [ __ ] brutal like
you know as soon as you know
you know so-called
um some types of entertainment if you
kind of catch a drift i mean basically
once they start kind of you know hanging
a little bit lower you're basically done
just going to be someone else knew how
to check
so i mean it's it's just you know it's a
classic you know a dodge if you know
fast money slower yeah if you that's
it that's it my sister has a little bit
of a tick tock following and i was
explaining to her that you can't like
if you build your following based on
like the way you look what what are you
gonna lead to how are you gonna make
money off of that
i'm like either either you can you can
take it further if you want and go go
into only fans or whatever but like like
then what's next what's next what's it
like
like and
i don't know that's that's kind of
cumbersome i think
how is your view on the world and like
relationships because a lot of women who
base their their their social media on
on their looks like
how many are single
entertainment
yeah
like your your
your man is that validation
that you get because of your looks
and so no guys ever good enough
or you're not going to be willing to do
the compromise
necessary to do to be with a man because
you're always going to have
the people that
the men and the women that value you for
your looks you know that's
that's why a lot of these freaking
instagram women they're single as all
hell
it's
[Music]
i think it's greed like
you know
or i guess gluttony the two but go ahead
i just was pearl's her turn to speak
relatively i think i'm good i'm i i'm
going to hop off though but it was good
to
talking to you both again and yeah i'll
be around
i'm going to look up this whole 40
uh money thing and how bad it's affected
the american dollar because i i i didn't
even realize that until you said it
thank goodness yeah it's that i mean how
else how else did they give everyone to
i didn't even lose my job and i got the
stimulus check like i still had the same
i was working in sales at the time i
sold the same job
why did i need it
just just you know oh my gosh like
what's up like
you know i'm not you know i'm
i
i try to be a positive guy i've had some
pretty hard times in my life but do you
mean like you have to
you can start
you can start being successful in your
life with just your words
and if you like
you just work on
already
like
go for it
what's that
i'll just say i didn't want to interrupt
so no
you know like you said that you don't
want to be like a doomsayer but you know
you're you you you need to look at this
where
you i tell everyone to look at that
you're going to be on this plane until
you're 75.
now that doesn't work out for
for everyone but the average age age is
that
and you can make things better man like
words
words turn into actions and oh
that's right bro real quick
if you don't if what you have doesn't
make you happy think about what you
don't have make a list of all the things
that you see your friends who are
failing in life that you don't have
you're a single man
you're not married to some crazy person
you don't have any kids at least not yet
[Laughter]
you're not in jail you don't have a
criminal record
these are all things that like there's
certain people in your life that would
kill there's someone somewhere who would
kill the bee
to be to be in your position and you've
made i think so you've made a lot of
good decisions
to make yourself work at work i'm pretty
sure
i was not married no kids i had a
criminal record and all you can do is
move forward man like yeah and just do
me a favor and start changing some of
your language around because
no i
i think i'm pretty successful as i am i
mean like okay no not not to high cap or
anything not to say oh everyone else
uh it's just like
i'm studying mechanical engineering
i would pretty confident to say that
most
most college students
probably can't do it
and i'm
four classes away six some some amount
between not
from graduating so i mean
and i'm uh most most people don't even i
think
actually i think most people start
college
but most people don't even get close to
finishing so i'm that's already what
like
a third of the population
so
i mean
yeah and not to and not to going into
the trades or you know that's that's all
cool too like i'm not saying like
college makes me better than anyone but
you know it's a sign of success so
yeah well you know
you're gonna be all right man you know
just just you like words become action
so try and like use better words
you know and don't be don't be so
self-deprecating man like you're like
like one thing one thing that us black
men need to start doing is giving
ourselves credit because no one else
will and and like you know this is the
first time in the two conversations i've
had where you've given yourself any type
of credit
so work on that at least
what i'm saying you know and one last
thing but most people think that you're
either moving forward or stepping
backwards
there's only two positions that's most
people like but there's three there's
moving forward stepping backwards and
then standing still
right now
you're waiting to get your degree and
you're kind of standing still
and you're waiting
you're trying to find the path to start
moving forward so just you know
don't just see everything as a step back
or a step forward you know what i'm
saying i'm completely fine with staying
still i actually think that's one
problem
earlier man
you know america
that's what people just don't know how
to settle just just do me a favor start
giving yourself more credit and stop
self-deprecating
society is going to do that enough to
you a lot of the women
you're going to meet
they're going to do that to you but you
shouldn't do that to yourself understand
i'm saying
yeah uh when it comes to
romantic interests like yeah
i don't think it's going on it's just
it's it's like okay huh oh yeah take
take care uh
uh i have to speak on like romantic
interests like the way i i i am who i am
like you know i'm not going to be like a
[ __ ] weirdo i mean right now i'm
in my pajamas my hair's
not not really presentable but like you
know i'm not going out to like high cap
for
practically anybody except for like if
i'm moments away from starving to get a
job but or a romantic interest like
you see for the most part it's what you
get if you don't like it that's cool you
know hey
my [ __ ] in a lot of ways it's
completely cool i don't have to be
everyone's cup of tea it's i get it you
know but you know
i'd rather be myself because
got to be company with yourself before
anyone else but us that's like another
thing i said original topic was you know
um
i don't know i just i just find like uh
kind of go back to financial security
it's like yeah i get like you know not
worrying about like the the major things
like yeah you you know especially if you
have a man's kids you don't want to okay
especially especially don't want to be
worried about being put on the street
but like a lot of chicks think like
oh i want financial security like oh i
want to go like skiing like he has to
consistent skiing trips like switzerland
like
every two months like
it's like
i don't think the majority of girls know
how to ski i'm going to be honest i i
don't think that most girls think that
are expected ski trips because i don't i
don't i have a lot of friends um
yeah and this isn't even like ratchet
girls like these are normal girls
and they get offered because my family
has a house in colorado free trips to go
ski
and rarely anyone takes it because they
don't want to learn how to ski
um just
um
no there's a lot of like normal girls
out there and i don't think the
manosphere
represents them that well like i've
asked a lot of friends like what their
minimum salary requirement is
and
for a guy our age it's i think 50k
for a guy that's your own eight like
25 and under that's fine 27 and under
um
so
i don't know if that's maybe not your
experience it doesn't seem like just
keep talking about how girls need to
settle
it's so weird so i'm and you know
they're not all back it's just
disagreements here and there i don't
even really participate or consider my
part like a part of manosphere i'm just
in a i just go to uga like uh even
though that's a public school the
average income for a family here
you'd be surprised for a public school
it is extremely high i think it's like a
quarter of a million a year for it
for the average student uh family income
it's like a quarter of a million dollars
a year so you're like you can just be
like like me like yeah kind of
like very low six figures on average you
go here and you start feeling [ __ ]
broke but when i go back to south
atlanta then i realize like nah we're
actually up i just go to somewhere
that's like hyper privileged so
but like it's like you kind of like look
at everybody a lot of my peers like i
guess you could say instagram stories
and just instagram accounts in general
and they're like
yeah uh you know not to beat myself up
too much but like i don't think like me
who's like uh you know i'm good with
like you know the two dollar
dunkin donuts coffee i don't think
though they're kind of on my same speed
a little bit so
yeah well i would i would never advise a
guy to date a girl that feels entitled
to his money like i i would never if a
girl's asking you it's one thing to ask
like like to have you pay for like a
first or second date but if a girl is
expecting you to like pay for everything
and feels entitled to your money
um that's definitely a red flag and i
would not tell any guy to keep talking
to her
yeah i i tend to i typically do like and
it's not like super harsh because i
understand you know we all have our
shortcomings but like after a while i
start my one of my shortcomings just
like i'm not very patient
uh so after a while i'm just like you
know it can even over like four dollar
coffee if it's just like if it feels
like i'm talking to a brick wall or it's
just like you know she's expecting me to
be like i guess the serpent i'm i'm not
going to even be like an [ __ ] cursor
out or anything i'm just going to be
like
i'm just going to do the fade away and
you know
yeah i don't i think like in early
stages of dating you don't really owe
people a super big explanation so that's
fine
yeah it's super weird um part of the
reason like i actually haven't gotten in
a long-term relationship because i'm
just so impatient
and it's it's just weird also um
it's my fifth year so second year being
a senior so most of people i know are
like about to graduate so we're all kind
of looking at each other like uh don't
want to get in a relationship before we
like move out to like i don't know
[ __ ]
california just
thousands of miles away
and like and it's also like just
radically different like um
family incomes because uh
i mean i grew up in south atlanta i'm
like i'm sorry like everyone else is
kind of like in the i guess you could
call it the money side of uh atlanta so
like i'd speak in like certain ways that
like
people just and i'm not blaming them
it's completely cool
but like it just don't really matter so
it's like uh you know
and i'm cool with like being with myself
you know i think that's like well where
are you going to meet girls
like
that's a very good question are you just
going to apps because i think apps kind
of put guys at a disadvantage
i have been using apps a little bit but
uh i mean i kind of do them
and you know a lot of like uh guys will
blame women for doing this but i think
maybe women to a greater extent but i
mean i do it too and a lot of guys do it
too i just use it for boredom i do it
like oh okay you know got up to
25 matches oh okay ooh and i got game
now and i'm not really like seriously
looking a lot of times on apps okay okay
um
you said sorry go ahead but where i like
i guess where i really look was actually
just my class this is actually really
really weird despite studying mechanical
engineering kind of like how college is
right now so uga is like i believe
basically two-thirds of uga is women so
like even engineering like my classes
are basically half and half at this
point you would think like mechanical
engineering like oh yeah that's like a
total softest pass it's not really so i
mean
so okay
um did you have anything else you wanted
to say about the topic
um
now i just kind of um i just kind of
want to say
i've been preached written like a really
good video on this it's like i think
like in a lot of ways you know social
media and kind of like our own limited
geographic areas what we see on a
general day we get like put in like such
a box of like this lofty expectations
you know oh you know
my my you know six the whole six figure
thing where i forget what it is it's
like you got to be six feet tall
six six figure six six uh six inches
long you know and it's like
okay so
um
the average man is i think i think
that's probably realistic yeah that's
very unrealistic for um
girls yeah that's very like all
that's a very small percentage of girls
and i don't think yeah we'll have those
outcomes um i do think that most girls
just want to get taller than them that's
fine
um
so a girl that's like and the average
girl is five five
i've asked like a lot of my friends just
because i ask i i ask red pill questions
pretty often only because
um
you know it's like they're interesting
topics so i try to like kind of
mix it with the real world and the
overwhelming response that i've gotten
from girls is that
they just want a guy that's taller than
them a big misconception
is that all good girls are in specific
places just because a girl goes to bible
does study doesn't mean she's wifey
material and if you need it
no that's absolutely true um
is that um
i see three types of people that go to
church the people that were raised in
church and actually believe it the
people that go to church because they
don't feel like they're good people and
they want to like be better and feel
like they're forgiven and the type of
people that go to church to make them
feel like better than other people those
are like the three maybe four is like
people that just go because their
husband or wife wants them to
yeah
yeah i
yeah just hearing herself you know going
big sec school i mean i see it all the
time like everyone's like pretty um even
uh pretty big churchgoers and it's just
like uh well
thank you guys uh it's it's super weird
like kind of being outside because i
actually never grew up in a church but
it's like i think you guys missed some
part of the bible but uh you know it's
not my business but it's like i kind of
just find it like and and kind of going
back to the whole hype thing i found
that whole thing kind of crazy because
like nope like absolutely no pun
intended i mean six four i don't know
six four so a five four is not a high
power to clear at all and it it'll be
funny too like you'll have like chicks
that are like obviously like like only
five feet tall but they're still like oh
yeah you know i want like someone who's
like five ten i was like how the [ __ ]
would you even know what that means how
would she even know how tall that is
if she wants that she can get it you
know just go for it i mean
sometimes
they're hot enough to make these demands
honest some girls are
and
i'm six foot so like i i clear most like
most requirements so i was like oh i
don't i don't care so personally
speaking but i just think like i mean
like
me being six foot that's not going to
like raise kids that's in most
industries that's not going to really
increase my salary if that's a big ill
i mean i get it statistically tall
people make more money
um okay i'm adding
things are looking up for me then
hi
what did you have to say hi
hi um
yeah well i think it was like
like like 83 percent of all c ceos are
males
over six foot tall
and then you think like
only like 12
percent of males are six foot or tall
taller so do the math
like height is one of the only things
that
people
it's weird in the same way that women
have looks yeah men have height you know
what i'm saying so like yeah six foot
tall or six foot one or six foot three
like i acknowledge that my height is a
good good good thing and i what am i
going to do be mad at the fact that it
gives me a benefit and you know what i'm
saying yeah so quick question how are
you real quick i'm six three
six okay i was going to say if we're
actually all six foot i would have been
like hey we're all basically like
no it's funny
the united states like
at the whole world we're in the top like
eight
percent or less of people on the planet
i've been to argentina paraguay
bolivia where they're like five foot two
and you're walking around like fifo from
it you know what i'm saying like it's
crazy they're staring at you like whoa
you know so yeah i mean i get it like in
terms of a lot of things like uh if if
you're a ceo you know you're a woman you
don't want like some like oopaloopa
looking now it's like i'm sorry
if you're
a ceo as a woman you said no i mean like
i mean because if you're a ceo i mean
even actually even then like i mean okay
if your co is like okay i'm i'm we're
all six foot or taller okay
at some level if your co is like i don't
know like five foot even you're gonna in
a certain way you're gonna look at them
like uh oh okay but
like
that there's certain skills that you
could that you can build to overcome
your height differentials because you
know uh i've met guys that are five foot
eight that have a very i don't want to
say intimidating presence well yeah i
have and then guys who have have
an assertive
presence
women who are five foot two that have a
an assertive presence that are that are
i know i know
and they're not aggressive but they just
have that presence like i should
probably be listening to what this
person has to say but i think that that
now like
so with the with the coronavir virus
right with the whole
covet thing
people were couldn't meet in person so
they had to kind of
talk on the phone or talk
like how we're talking now and realize
that they didn't know how to talk to
each other you know they didn't want to
text anymore so like people realize how
terrible that their soft skills really
are you know like people can't hold
conversations anymore people can't
communicate
they haven't practiced these skills
where like i'm a
natural extrovert so i don't get how
peop people don't have soft skills
that's just me you know but i understand
that i work
with a lot of
scientists and those who don't have
these skills and it just amazes me that
to socialize it's draining to them
when i i did this um
project a couple years ago i decided i
wanted more i wanted more rich friends i
just like decided one day i was like my
friends are too broke it's time to watch
people
[Laughter]
and so i like
y'all [ __ ]
no i'm kidding sort of but i went to
these i went to these big companies and
i was just like
all right guys can i can i talk to some
of your like executives and just like
hang out with them and like i got the
cio of harley davidson to get like
coffee with me and like i got these like
big executives to get coffee with me
and
it's interesting they were all over like
six foot even the girl
oh
you know i'm not going i'm not gonna lie
i'm sorry and i'm sorry when i when i
was a girl she's like like 62. like
because i used to live in um the athlete
storm at uga that was weird
yeah that's cool and like we're like a
huge sports school like unfortunately
lost the sec championship whole
different conversation but like we
record for a ton of schools we have
women's basketball volleyball so like i
used to live in a student dorm you know
i would go down do my laundry like i'm
some freshman don't know what's going on
i see it feels like chick that's like
three walking down the hallway looking
like she could like throw me over
shoulder i'm like uh mom uh i need to go
like
no i i get it like in a ceo like at some
level like i i guess really does matter
it's just have to determine like what
extent but like i'm just saying like
i mean
if you're like physical appearance in a
lot of ways it's kind of like a sign of
like i guess like dominant so like i
don't know like
i've had bosses that were shorting
because a lot of my bosses were women in
the past kind of like level of jobs is
what it is but like i mean if they were
just like like a whole foot shorter to
me i'm just like uh oh okay then
but
well it depends on if they're trying to
pull rank or not because a good man
manager or a good leader
you do things for them because you want
to and not because you have to right
yeah that's true so i've had
bosses where you're like well you don't
even think about they ask you hey can
you do do this you're not cool then
everyone's had that you're going to do
this because i said so and you're like
you think so huh you know
and that's not the type of
type of person i am but pearl i dropped
off
really fast when you're talking about
having rich friends i'm the type of
person where i have different
types of friends too so i have like my
my my phd friends then my you know my
friends from the gym and then my friends
from like from the from the kickback of
boxing people are doing it it's just a
joke
have you ever have you ever tried to mix
friends on accident so so like i've had
one of my friends from the gym that's
like a younger dude right and he just
has like a regular job and then like i'm
like hey let's
let's go hang out with some of my more
bougie friends and we'll go to your
place and then your one friend that's
like
doesn't make a lot of money looks at the
menu and he's like oh
you're like oh i forgot like you weren't
you weren't boozy like the rest of this
crowd god i'm saying
you can't mix that that group you know
what i'm saying so
kind of interesting
but the question was yes it said um
he said what makes a husband
yeah what makes a guy a husband material
and what makes a girl wife material well
i think that what
what makes a guy husband
material hasn't changed women expect men
to do all the same stuff just a lot of
them
can't admit that that's what they want
guys to do right so i know plenty of my
friends who were who got married like
straight out of grad school
and their wives are the only one out of
their group of
of women that are married
and
like
they get all this
they get hate from their friends
and then when their friends go i can't
believe i'm single i want to find a guy
who's like you're a husband it's like
well you just said in one breath that
that you don't want a a traditional
masculine man blah blah blah but out
here that's
how she's but here's the thing dude like
you're how old are you
oh bro i'm young i'm the youngest but
the thing is i'm 22.
you're you're only 22. dude i'm still
lost in the sauce no no no dude you
you shouldn't even be thinking about
dating seriously until your late 20s man
you can still date obviously you can
still meet women really really think
about like but you gotta understand
what's that yeah late 20s i'm talking
about to actually get serious and settle
down and get and get get get married i'm
not gonna talk about having sex and
everything whatever
what i'm saying is this
you got huge generation focuses too
too much on like online dating for
instance and like
yeah
it's pretty crunchy but but studies show
that like speed day dating is 70
percent more effective than online
dating because you have a in-person
interaction so you just you ever been to
like this
a speed dating thing
i've been a
somewhere i've been on a lot of days so
i just
so my question is i i think
statistically meeting people online is
one of the number one ways people meet
today yes but what are they meeting with
for
what are they meeting for no i mean like
i think relationships and like marriage
like one of the number one ways that
people met their significant other was
online well they have to like aggregate
that by like by age or something because
i know a lot of people people that that
have met online but most of where i work
we have like phd students that are 28
to 40 and then we have the old people
people but a lot of my
cohort started getting married when they
were like 34 30 35 and having kids
a lot of them met online because they're
professionals and they're working but
all of my other friends who are 25 they
only meet to hook up they don't even go
out on dates they just bang each other
you know what i'm saying and that's it
they're meeting to actually have related
relationships
because what's what's the point you can
just
meet and break up with some
someone swipe left swipe right and
you're ready ready to go you know that's
lame that's lame as [ __ ] though i'm part
of that
but the thing is is this if you want to
meet a quality person person get rid of
the
online land part and do as much in
person meeting as possible speed dating
go to like if you
exercise go to like um 5ks and 10ks
those are like 70 percent female anyways
i will say as i will say as a girl um
like women don't get approached often in
person
and if you're a guy and you can actually
approach women if you can get good at
approaching women in person
but that's not going to happen anymore
because of the me you do thing because
yeah yeah don't think about it think i
think
think about it you used to have to
back when i was in high school and in
college right you used to have have you
have to go up to a girl in front of
everyone you'd be at a house party or a
bar you get the old snap you walk up to
her and if
if you got this because everyone's
watching you
damn bro they got like the spotlight on
you like yeah you had you said
like i just see you like a shoddy like
you know yeah
like what are you doing aside why how
you doing if she said
then you had to walk all the way back
and everyone's like oh you know but now
um
that
um rejection can be criminalized now
every person has their own boundaries
right and the thing about this modern
interpretation of
of this me too thing is a
small group of women have decided that
they're gonna wonder twin powers
activate and speak for all women and say
this
we have spoke for all women and this is
what we don't want but there's other
women who say wait a minute no i'm i
want guys to approach me i want guys
yeah forward with how
they think and and then guys are saying
i cannot magically psychically know what
every woman's boundary is yeah we can't
hold on
no i'm saying like that's not a lot in
every state where you can't approach
someone i'm saying like
i if you go up to a girl and ask for her
number in person what is she gonna do
other than say no
but now you don't know i usually give
her my number like no right because i'm
texting you like what the [ __ ] because
i figured this
this out at a young
young age because i've always done done
well with women but i had a friend dan
back in college he was a half tie and
half german jaws jawline natural
six-pack so i noticed that we would try
it we would take our friend of ours
jonas who was just a troll right there
this guy
i'm talking about he would guard bridges
he was just ugh
we would have him and dan go to the same
girl and say the same thing
and dan would get her no
number and joe
because dan was cute and jonas what was
it yeah they would say the exact same
thing so what i'm saying is something as
as subjective as
attraction or game
to be able to say that this person may
be unco comfortable and i can call some
type of authority on them it's too big
of a risk now mm-hmm yeah that's true
and and you went to college college and
um work those are the two play places
where women would meet their their
spouses college and work and now
colleges are saying no more parties no
more nothing because we we want um
sexual acts assault down and then
workplaces are saying men and women
cannot fraternize anymore because we
cannot risk a law lawsuit and then women
say well
i i can't meet anyone so well this is
what you wanted which is
assault has gone down so it is so it has
one yeah
careful what you wish for you know what
i'm saying and what i'm saying is i'm
not
dating now because i'm engaged but
hey congrats i would never ever like i
would not want to date now nowadays i
would i mean it's a
kind of like what kevin samuel said like
i mean dating is like it's it's not
it's not something you want to stick
around like doing all the time
it's a means to an end like i wanna i
wanna date cause like i'm trying to have
some [ __ ] happen
is this dude back when i was 22 you were
far too young to have such a negative
view of dating dude like like i i've
been to me through i've been through it
man you know what i'm saying and like i
think it's fine like
i'm very optimistic in that
this corona virus and i don't want this
youtube thing to get get get dinged
because i've said
covet and coronavirus on your stream
like so just say it again then i guess
but oh damn
women really did
get stuck in the house for eight months
by themselves and they're now taught to
be them
in a relationship [ __ ] violin
seriously it took an act of god for a
lot of my
female friends to look look and they're
like oh snap like what am i doing like
where did [ __ ] not
and what i'm saying is i know plenty of
guys that are happy playing
xbox by themselves well i know
a lot of girls who aren't and they're
just straight up saying like look i
don't want to be alone i don't
and
this isn't fun but here's the thing in
the same way that i feel as an extrovert
a lot of my introverted friends i feel
like that though they
introverts
are kind of selfish because they want
the world to deal with them on theirs
and their standards and their way a lot
of women who who are dating or dealing
with guys want guys to deal with them in
the exact way that they want and that
that's what happened
and you got to be like hey baby girl
that's that's not how it goes
it's a
it's a social dance people yeah yeah
and there's more women
than there are men period
especially
think about that about it so it's just
it's it's tough and that
but to marriage though like i think that
the number one thing
that men
need to be is
is obviously there's a
there's the provider
protector thing so like
my girl knows if we go out you know if
anyone messes with
with her they're getting [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] up you know what i'm saying like
it's my job to
protect her that's just that's what i
signed up for
oh i'll provide for her
for she yeah
worse than does everything but if she
wanted to quit her job right now i'm i'm
fine with that okay i'm saying
and
um i expect her to put up with my
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying i'm
not the easiest person to live with but
she puts up with hers i put up
one now my girl and i we aren't gonna
have it
have any kids but i say say this in the
same way that a man has to like
she as a person that i'm gonna marry
has to be be willing to be on my program
meaning that
she doesn't answer to me but like
our relationship means like if i were to
get a job in san francisco
that's a big promotion right mm-hmm yeah
we're going
mm-hmm we're going
you know what i'm saying we're going to
talk about it
about it but all in all she doesn't want
to be the one in in front hard charging
barreling through the you know well i
don't think that's natural for girls
like we don't like jumping over dog
donkey kong barrels
okay guys
i just looked at the time it's like four
thanks so much for coming up thanks so
much for coming on um please come on
next time yeah uh i will yeah there's no
there's no good ringing of me yeah i'll
find the chicken
good one stay safe okay bye